in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Scott
and Addie are with us hey guys how are
ya good
hi welcome welcome where do you guys
live Monrovia Indiana and what is that
near it's just west of Indianapolis okay
we'll call it Indianapolis very cool and
you guys are here to do your debt-free
scream and how much debt have you paid
off
we paid off sixty three thousand and
twenty months all right and making what
kind of money during that time we
started out making forty two thousand a
year and we ended making eighty two
thousand a year not about raised in 20
months what happened to your income I
think go up so much I got a job okay all
right that's good that's good that adds
to the income a lot very cool what do
you guys do for a living what do you do
for a living I'm sorry I um I'm retired
Air Force uh-huh and right now I'm just
going to school okay very cool good and
daddy what do you do I work for a title
company oh okay
making 82 oh no the 82 includes the
retirement okay Wow I was thinking
that's pretty good okay it's still
pretty good
excellent very well done so what kind of
debt was the 63 thousand also at ease
stigma 100% of it yes Wow how long have
you guys been married five years
yesterday oh well happy anniversary
thank you so what happened 20 months ago
that made you guys change directions
after five years of marriage well I
heard your show on the radio of driving
home and I told her I was like hey we
need to check this book out and she's
like well I'm telling to read a book
right now in the next couple days she
signed us up for the SPU class so that's
what happened all right so Adi what
happened when he told you read the book
all of a sudden you jump on board go big
or go home I realized that we needed to
get it together we have two young kids
and we needed to change the legacy of
our family tree yeah very cool and so
you end up in a Financial Peace
University class and that gets this
whole thing started so you guys have
really I mean do you sell
some stuff how did you do this we just
cut back on eating out you come back on
everything yeah our grocery bill our
spending money just anything we had a
garage sale to make a couple hundred
bucks anything that we could think of
well this is impressive sixty three
thousand and twenty months making eighty
two is impressive that's very very well
done so that had to be hard it wasn't
harder than you thought it was going to
be or easier than you thought it was
gonna be when you started definitely
harder yeah I would definitely agree I
think it was probably harder for me I'm
the spender okay alright and what do you
tell people the secret to getting out of
debt is because you've done it now
definitely I stick with the budget it's
alright it's hard to stick with it but
you have to if you want to get out of it
yeah absolutely
what about you at it I I would agree
it's all about budgeting you have to
stick with the budget communication yeah
that's what Sharon always says she's is
communication communication
communication always wants more
communication that's right very good
well congratulations you guys thanks for
coming down from the Indianapolis area
thank you you're debt-free scream scott
and adi sixty three thousand dollars
paid off in 20 months making forty two
up to eighty two now count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream three two one
well done you two
very well done hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you are not a victim
you're not a victim of big corporations
you're not a victim of Wall Street
you're not a victim of capitalism you're
not a victim of wealth inequality you're
not a victim of racism you're not a
victim